mesdames et messieurs bonsoir je suis
désolé de vous annoncer un accident
affreux survenu cet après midi dans la
région de barcelonnette dans les
alpes-de-haute-provence sur le
territoire de la commune du lauzet on
déplore 17 morts et quatre blessés
graves parmi les passagers d'un car
militaire qui a basculé au lieu-dit le
pas de la tour et qui s'est écrasé à 60
mètres en contrebas les victimes sont
des adolescents appartenant à des
familles d'habitants d'istres dans les
bouches-du-rhône
la cause de l'accident le verglas
semble-t-il la chapelle du bail à 10 km
du lauzet est transformée en chapelle
ardente
elle a été construite cette chapelle il
ya 20 ans au moment où le village qui
est un fruit sous les eaux d'un lac
artificiel
cet après midi comme il n'y avait pas
assez de cercueils les corps des
victimes ont été enveloppés de draps et
allongé pour le moment côte à côte
vi est mort quatre blessés la plupart
des adolescents et 16h à la 62e foire
internationale de lyon la plus
importante depuis 15 ans a été inaugurée
aujourd'hui par le président de la
république en compagnie du premier
ministre
deux manifestations s'étaient déroulées
peu auparavant d'une part un millier de
motards venus de plusieurs régions
notamment de marseille et du var
s'étaient groupés place bellecour pour
partir ensuite en cortège tournée dans
le quartier des brotteaux et aux abords
du palais des expositions
et c'est également aux abords du parc
des expositions qui s'était réuni des
militants de la cgt du parti communiste
c'est à dire selon la fpp 150 à 200
personnes qui ont procédé à une
distribution de tracts avant l'ordre de
dispersion donné vers 11 aucun incident
n'a été enregistré
sinon une circulation fortement
perturbée
à l'occasion de l'inauguration de cette
foire internationale de lyon le
président a fait un éloge appuyé du
premier ministre à présent a déclaré que
seul compte la raison le sang-froid le
courage la détermination et
l'obstination
monsieur giscard d'estaing a ajouté que
c'est bien là l'état d'esprit que
manifeste au gouvernement avec à sa tête
monsieur raymond barre dont la
compétence est justement la
détermination le courage
mark grant du président cette période et
assureront au premier ministre l'estimé
la reconnaissance des français un compte
rendu de panama ce nouvel hommage rendu
à raymond barre et significatif
valéry giscard d'estaing voulu ainsi
encouragé le premier ministre à
poursuivre la même politique malgré les
critiques émises par les dirigeants de
certains partis pour valéry giscard
d'estaing s'est en effet seuls cette
politique qui a permis à la france de
devenir le troisième ou le quatrième
exportateur mondial et qui a permis à la
france de relever par exemple en 79 sa
production de 4 % pour valéry giscard
d'estaing ses résultats devrait donc
rassurer les français
mais la discipline ne doit pas être
relâché pour autant discipline des
français tout d'abord qui doivent
comprendre que s'il ya un surplus sa
répartir ce sur plus devra aller aux
plus défavorisés discipline de l'état
ensuite qui doit alléger la charge qui
pèse sur les français valéry giscard
d'estaing a demandé au gouvernement
d'effectuer l'année prochaine une pause
fiscale
le prélèvement cotisation et en
cotisations sociales et en impôts a
atteint pour le chef de l'état sa limite
voilà les conditions économiques et
sociales de la réussite mais pour le
président de la république il ya aussi
une condition politique qu'il a définie
en demandant aux français de suivre ce
qu'il appelle la ligne du juste milieu
laissez moi vous dire un mot de la ligne
politique que je poursuis et à laquelle
j'entends bien me tenir
c'est la ligne du juste milieu celle de
la synthèse des propositions de la
rencontre des hommes de la mobilisation
des forces pour aider la france et non
pour déchirer la france ce n'est pas une
ligne neutre
c'est une ligne de paix et d'entente à
suivre avec beaucoup de soin dans ces
temps de tempête il faut vous souvenir
de ce fille on entend exprimer beaucoup
de critiques mais lorsqu'on tient la
ligne du juste milieu
on est exposé à subir deux fois plus de
critiques que lorsqu'on adopte une
position extrême on tire sur vous des
deux bords que chacun le comprenne
deux fois plus de critiques si l'on
tient le juste milieu et c'est pourtant
la ligne juste celle où peuvent un jour
se rencontrer se réunir et se rassembler
les français et c'est ce qu'ils
appellent une mise en garde pour ces
temps difficiles on peut critiquer le
juste milieu
mais le foie des politiques extrêmes
ferait chavirer le navire ses gardes
ensuite de son texte le chef de l'état a
constaté lorsque j'observe le
déroulement de la vie publique je
ressens de la peine devant les divisions
des antagonismes d'excessif des
dirigeants politiques de la france
j'ai de la peine dit monsieur giscard
d'estaing parce que cette situation
n'est pas digne de notre pays nous
sommes à ma connaissance le seul pays
démocratique du monde dont les
dirigeants principaux des quatre
formations politiques qui exprime notre
vie nationale ne se rencontrent pas 2 à
ni dans la majorité ni dans l'opposition
ni maintenant entre la majorité et
l'opposition
malgré la bonne volonté de certains j'ai
parcouru beaucoup de pays du monde me
dit parfois que l'on parcourt tranche
représente la france mais partout où je
suis allé dans les pays démocratiques
j'ai jamais vu une telle situation
je ne demande pas bien entendu la
disparition du débat démocratique je ne
demande pas qu'on soit d'accord mais il
y à de vastes sujets à débattre la
politique extérieure de la france la
politique de défense de la france les
orientations notre politique économique
et social tout ceci justifie la
rencontre tout ceci justifie le dialogue
et quand je dis que ce n'est pas digne
de la france c'est comment voulez vous
que nous prenions le dialogue dans le
monde et comment voulez vous que nous
recommandions la participation à
l'intérieur si nous ne sommes pas
capables entre nous au niveau des
responsables de nous rencontrer et de
dialoguer et de participer et je vous
dirai ensuite que ces nuisibles à
l'intérêt de la france d'avancer
nuisible à sa réputation
si quelqu'un dont l'ambition j'ai
d'ailleurs écrit plusieurs reprises
c'est que la france apparaissent
toujours dans le monde comme ce qu'il y
a de meilleur et croyez vous que cette
impossibilité pour les dirigeants de la
france de débattre entre deux des
problèmes de notre pays nous fassent
apparaître comme un pays exemplaire
comme un pays d'avant garde comme un
pays à imiter le congrès de l'udf s'est
achevée aujourd'hui à orléans les
congressistes ont adopté à l'unanimité
moins deux abstentions
une déclaration qui représente six mois
de réflexion et de travaux en commission
dans ce texte les eps souhaite en
particulier une croissance économique
soutenue et appuyée sur une nouvelle
conception de la planification la
politique étrangère est une place
importante dans ces débats et surtout
les questions du proche orient qui ont
provoqué quelques
dans son discours de clôture monsieur
jean le cam et président de l'udf
présente le point de vue de son gros lp
doit renoncer à la destruction de l'état
d'israël
dans cette perspective son leader ne
peut nourrir à nos yeux son projet de
visite en france qu'en acceptant de
renoncer à ce qu'on appelle l'article 19
de la chape de l'ol paie qui se donne
pour objectif inacceptable la
destruction de l'état d'israël
la politique extérieure souhaité est
tracée par l'udf et du totale clarté
à cet égard
s'il faut insister pour qu'il ne
subsiste aucune obscurité je dirais que
le droit à l'existence et à la sécurité
de l'état d'israël doit tête
définitivement reconnue par tous
on s'attendait bien à ce que le
président du df dans son discours de
clôture soit amené à évoquer les
rapports entre israël et les
palestiniens
c'était à vrai dire le seul point de
friction entre militants des diverses
formations au cours de ce congrès un
congrès particulièrement sage est calme
il ne fait aucun doute que jean lecanuet
réussi à gommer les aspérités du débat
apaisé les craintes de ceux qui
critiquent la politique française au
proche orient
mais si monsieur le calme et a réussi
c'est avant tout parce qu'il a
rapidement aiguilles et ses propos sur
la voie des présidentielles et que pour
faire se serrer les coudes des
giscardiens rien n'est meilleur que de
parler de valéry giscard d'estaing avec
en prime un appel aux chiraquiens pour
que soit instituée en quelque sorte un
code de bonne conduite
si nos partenaires de la majorité
veulent se compter au premier tour
puisse-t-il c'est la de vente que je
leur adresse ne pas compromettre par
l'excès d'une campagne l'union
nécessaire au deuxième tour la politique
du juste milieu et l'idée nationale ces
préoccupations exprimées par le
président de la république alliant des
copains les avez vous ressenti en étant
au milieu des congressistes de l'udf
bien notons d'abord que ce sont aux
thèmes très giscardien et déjà plusieurs
années avant d'être élu président de la
république valéry giscard d'estaing et
disait que la france devait être
gouverné au centre quant à l'unité on
peut dire que c'est le thème qui était
le plus constamment évoqué par le
président la république depuis qu'il est
à l'elysée alors le juste milieu à
orléans je crois qu'on peut dire qu
orléans était un congrès très centriste
mmo au gré des interventions de ci de là
on a pu noter des réactions qui était
disons assez conservatrices et puis en
revanche l'affirmation d'une volonté
d'aller plus vite et plus loin quand l
unité et bien elles étaient exprimées
d'une le besoin d'unité est exprimée
d'une façon assez pittoresque par un
orateur qui a demandé qu il
après l'élection présidentielle un
grenelle politique en se référant à la
grande négociation sociale du grenelle
de 1968 mais il faut bien dire qu'en
fait d'unités l'udf était surtout
préoccupé de sa propriété sur quoi peut
reposer sur ip du dr et bien
essentiellement sur valéry giscard
d'estaing lui-même l'udf il faut bien le
dire est encore un rassemblement de
familles qui sont bien différentes
et ces familles ont sans doute déjà un
intérêt commun mais ils n'ont pas encore
une histoire commune et cela se sentait
s'il ya eu un vote unanime les orateurs
les plus chevronnés et les plus
talentueux ont pu se rendre compte qu'il
n'était pas facile de faire vibrer
unanimement ce concret chose assez
curieuse l'orateur le plus applaudi a
été aussi l'homme politique qui était
peut-être le plus discuté avant le
congrès dit débarque didier bariani
président du parti radical et il était
très applaudi pour avoir dit qu'il
soutiendrait valéry giscard d'estaing
tout simplement parce que c'était le
meilleur alors je crois qu'on peut dire
que l'udf trouvera vraiment son unité
lorsque dans la mobilisation qui était
décrété la mobilisation présidentielle
qui était décrétée tout à l'heure par
jean le cam yeux mais elle a quand même
pas de mes parents pour vous faire
danser sur un an
et oui c'est justement je crois la
difficulté peut-être un peu une des
contradictions de l'udf qui se
mobilisent bien longtemps avant la
candidature de celui est donc
précisément elle souhaite la candidature
et l'autre difficulté est bien c'est que
l'udf veut être le parti du président
sans pour autant faire que le président
apparaissent comme étant le candidat de
ce parti
on peut dire que l'udf a encore bien du
mal à affirmer sa personnalité et que si
elle soutient le président de la
république
c'est en fait ce soutien qui fait son
existence à elle le psu fêté ce week end
à paris au palais des arts 120e
anniversaire les discussions étaient
organisées autour de l'éventuelle
centrale nucléaire de plogoff des
atteintes aux libertés les problèmes des
femmes et de la recherche de nouveaux
modes de vie un commentaire de daniel
brel le parti politique non pierre
mendès-france et michel rocard sur un
nombre ne s'est pas attardé autre mesure
a dressé le bilan de ses 20 ans d'action
pour participer à ces laboratoires
d'idées il avait invité
plusieurs protestataires comme j'en ai
les chaînes du parti communiste marco
pannella du parti radical italien ou
l'écologiste brice l'allant huguette
bouchardeau secrétaire national du psu
je voudrais bien découvrir découvrir une
autre manière de faire de la politique
une chose est sûre c'est que le dégoût
de la politique telle qu'elle se fait à
l'heure actuelle est partagée par
beaucoup et que finalement ce dégoût et
très mauvais parce qu'ils risquent de
causer un désintérêt qui serait fatal à
la démocratie bien ce qu'il faudrait
faire c'est que les jeunes qui
aujourd'hui ont prises en charge par
exemple une part de cette vie locale
associative qui s'occupe de quelque
chose dans leur coin dans leur région
dans leur localité
puis savoir part dans la vie politique
et qu'elle ne soit pas seulement
prise en charge par quelques leaders
d'opinion ce serait déjà un point très
important
et puis il faudrait aussi que la vie
politique ne soit pas seulement
cantonnée dans le domaine des
institutions les élections les grands
problèmes de l'état il faudrait aussi
que ces problèmes de la vie quotidienne
puisse être en rapport avec les
problèmes de l'état
c'était je crois lénine qui disait qu'il
faudrait que la cuisinière puisse faire
de la politique je crois que le jour où
les gens simples pourront comprendre
quelque chose au discours politique
à partir de ce moment là il y aura
réellement quelque chose de changé parce
qu'on ne laissera plus berner par les
gens qui possèdent les privilèges de
l'argent du pouvoir de la parole voulez
vous oui ou non du nucléaire c'est la
question à laquelle devait répondre
aujourd'hui les suédois la suède possède
déjà des réacteurs en activité sans
programme nucléaire prévoit la mise en
service de six autres ces prochaines
années
or un nombre de plus en plus élevées de
ce fait doit être fait doit se
manifestent leur désaccord depuis
quelques temps des gouvernements sont
même tombés à cause de la question
nucléaire
et c'est pour toutes ces raisons que la
population a mais une passion presque
inhabituelle a préféré sera préparé ce
référendum
martine laroche-joubert
malgré le vent et le froid et var anne
catherine lyon thomas compte apporter
guitare et contrebasse et on branche m
crawl
comme tous les matins depuis trois
semaines ils mènent une guerre en
chanson contre le nucléaire
ce sont des partisans de l'option numéro
3 celle qui dit non à l'atome les
options une et deux ont chacune leur
manière de dire oui
depuis l'annoncé d'un référendum sur le
nucléaire quelque chose a changé dans le
royaume de suède
les suédois que l'on disait installés
dans le confort du programme et ont
découvert la passion le goût de se
battre pour un avenir qu'ils choisiront
eux-mêmes le goût de se battre mais à la
suédoise
c'est à dire les mots pratiquement et
sans violence au coin des rues les
discussions s'engagent les musiciens
prêtent leurs micros à des
contradicteurs
on reconnaît à leur badge blanc de
l'énergie pour la suède
ce sont surtout les problèmes sécurité
et d'approvisionnement en énergie qui
sont évoqués ici
la suède est l'un des pays où sont
écrits d'énergie dans le money de par
habitant les haines n'a ni pétrole ni
charbon pour répondre à toutes ces
questions chaque option chaque ligne et
comme il dit ici installé un centre
d'informations sur les grandes places de
stockholm
rien n'est laissé au hasard pour mieux
informer mieux faire comprendre le
problème nucléaire au suédois
la nuit même pas de repos pour les
militants antinucléaires
chaque quartier de la capitale est
quadrillée sous l'autorité d'un chef de
secteur ici c'est paul qui dirige les
opérations pour la deuxième fois en
quinze jours il parcourt les escaliers
de cet immeuble
tous les militants sont bénévoles mais
l'option numéro 3 comme les deux autres
a reçu une importante subvention du
gouvernement pour mener sa campagne
chef de file de ce mouvement leenhardt
d'aller vous ce site ici dans ses
bureaux de l'ancien parlement de
stockholm colonnes imagine peut-être la
prochaine façon d'exister
en réalité les gens donnent à ce
mouvement un jeu de signification qui
n'en a réellement
ce n'est pas un mouvement socialiste ce
n'est pas un moment bourgeois c'est le
regroupement d'une quarantaine
d'associations très différentes
je voudrais dire que ce n'est pas une
nouvelle culture c'est plutôt une
espérance différents dans le futur une
espérance de vivre dans un monde qui ne
ressemble pas un monde industrialisé
une nouvelle manière de vivre peut-être
mais l'important est de garder son
emploi riposte les partisans de l'option
numéro 2 celle d'un programme nucléaire
nationaliser soutenu par les sociaux
démocrates
alors c'est dans les chantiers qui
mènent leur campagne avec l'appui du
tout puissant syndicat ouvrier
c'est la crainte de l'avenir la crainte
d'une baisse du niveau de vie
entraîné par l'abandon du nucléaire qui
ici fait réfléchir je pense que les gens
âgés les ouvriers et tous ceux qui
travaillent dans l'industrie comprennent
que nous avons besoin d'énergie si nous
ne pourrons pas développer l'industrie
chinoise
pourtant c'est nécessaire car nous avons
de grosses difficultés économiques
comprendre que nous devons contrôler nos
sources d'énergie j'ai décidé de voter
pour l'option numéro deux c'est la
meilleure façon de dire oui au nucléaire
l'option numéro trois fait trop appel à
l'imagination
ils ne savent pas ils ne savent pas de
quoi ils parlent
bien sûr tout le monde est contre nous
faire mais nous devons tenir compte de
la réalité une campagne pour chacun
dépense son énergie à sa manière
efficacité sérieux pour le pro nucléaire
spectaculaire et brillante pour les
opposants qui ont la majorité des
intellectuels dans leur camp est-ce que
vous pensez que la plupart des artistes
des acteurs sont contre le nucléaire
je crois et pourquoi explique peut-être
parce qu'on sent plihon sont plus on
n'est pas en experts n'osent pas et on
ne peut pas on prend pas tellement par
de la politique alors on sent et on lit
et on voit ce qui se passe dans la
nature
ici les acteurs mettent autant de fougue
à recueillir les noms qu'ils n'en
mettaient à recueillir les
applaudissements ils ont imaginé
l'histoire d'une femme de ménage qui
avait toujours dit oui avant de dire non
au nucléaire
est ce que c'est la première fois que
vous prenez un engagement public et
pourquoi ne faites-vous ça parce que je
suis très engagé de cette question j'ai
peur j'aime bien la vie et je pense que
quand on fait pas prendre les
conséquences pour les générations qui
suivent alors on n'a pas le droit
chose alors cette centrale sera t elle
fermer avant disons qu'on me demande les
antinucléaires ou continuera-t-il à
tourner pendant 25 ans au moins pour le
moment
louis procèdent les noms mais l'écart
diminue de jour en jour
réponse le 23 mars nous y sommes
alors les bureaux de vote n'ont cessé d
opération qui lie à un quart d'heure
mais on sait qu'il a eu 80 % de votants
à peu près et que les sondages donnent
pour l'ensemble des votants environ 58 %
de bulletins favorables au nucléaire et
36% à ses adversaires ces chiffres de
sondages n'ont évidemment rien
d'officiel par ailleurs trois médecins
américains qui milite contre le danger
selon eux croissant de guerre nucléaire
ont indiqué à washington avoir reçu hier
une lettre de monsieur brejnev
approuvant leurs actions le numéro un
soviétique affirme que son pays et je
cite est en faveur de l'interdiction de
telles armes ainsi que tous les autres
types d'armes de destruction massive et
d'annihilation télégramme de l'étranger
italie monsieur que six gars premier
ministre démissionnaire chargé de former
le nouveau gouvernement pense y parvenir
des deux laurent hassan ii du maroc est
arrivé aujourd'hui à paris venant de
marrakech son séjour est présentée par
l'elysée comme une visite de travail le
roi hassan et le président de la
république se rencontreront trois fois
la semaine prochaine il y aura notamment
deux déjeuners de travail dont pain
élargie et un dîner offert par le
président en l'honneur du souverain
marocain jute un télégramme qui est
arrivé après le début de ce journal de
panama l'ex attirant à quitter le panama
aujourd'hui en début de soirée c'est ce
qu'a annoncé la délégation iranienne qui
devait demander demain
aux autorités panaméennes l'extradition
de l'ancien souverain car land is est
atterrant ceux d'après midi que le sort
des otages est d' extradition éventuelle
de l'ex shah d'iran était encore tout à
fait lié on ignorait peu après 19h gmt
c'est à dire peu après 20 heures
françaises disons qu'on ignorait encore
il ya quelques minutes
quelle était la destination de l'echa je
pense pour avoir du tout autre dépêche
que ce pourrait être l'une des îles
basses
le pape a honoré aujourd'hui
saint-benoît que l'on appelait en son
temps le père de l'europe le pape
s'était rendu à 9,6 lieu natal de saint
benoît à 150 km de rome où devant trente
mille personnes et sous la pluie il a
célébré la messe est jean paul ii a
rappelé que saint benoît jadis à une
époque de profondes transformations
alors que l'ancien ordre romain
s'écroulait et qu'une nouvelle société
allait naître sous la poussée dos des
populations que saint-benoît donc à
assumer une tâche dont la portée
religieuse et sociale fut considérable
l'europe a poursuivi jean paul ii revenu
à ses frontières par suite des derniers
grands conflits mondiaux peut encore de
nos jours ce inspiré de l'oeuvre de
saint benoît il y a 20 ans l'église
catholique au québec et est considérée
comme la plus traditionaliste ou même
réactionnaire au monde
hier les évêques du québec ont nommé une
femme catholique secrétaire-général de
le rassembler lors peut-on se demander
l'église québécoise est elle passée du
plus rétrograde au plus progressistes au
cours d'un récent voyage dans la
province francophone du canada
maurice werther a essayé de répondre à
cette interrogation
la salle qui s'échappe est qu en temps a
déclaré tout rose 4 ans c'est du sexe ça
sert sainte adèle
une petite grosse boulette avec des
lunettes rondes et moustache qui fut
celle cptaq d'une cuisine on met ça
comptait pas vraiment c'est ta soeur
folle du couvent qui en plus vive est
ouvertement en état de péché mortel
depuis 25 ans dans les cafés-théâtres du
québec on n'hésite plus à se moquer de
la religion catholique a tourné en
dérision l'église et les religieux
jadis tout puissant depuis 1960
une véritable révolution culturelle a
bouleversé les structures moral de la
belle province
celle où se trouve 90 % des canadiens
qu'il parle français et 90 % des
catholiques du canada autrefois 95% de
la population du québec allait à la
messe aujourd'hui 15% et dans la classe
intellectuelle ou artistique de montréal
il est de bon ton de railler la religion
telle qu'on la pratiquait il y à 25 ans
maintenant au québec on peut se moquer
de la religion impunément
non ça dépend où vous à moi mais c'est
les gens dans la salle quand tu regardes
ça les réactions de le monde rit
beaucoup en fait mais il ya beaucoup de
haut
des choses des trucs c'est pas fini les
gens sont encore choqués oui mais ils
sont aussi choqués par sa part la pièce
comme tel qui dénoncent cependant des
choses
même au niveau politique lloris 5 1
c'était la religion fait partie de la
culture
elle s'était très très peu intériorisé
plus avec tout le chambardement culturel
j'ai fait au québec surtout fait ça à
tomber avec comme d'autres valeurs
culturelles
c'était sûr qu'aujourd'hui là c'est une
réelle évangélisation on sait j'ai la
foi
et puis c'est une chance pour moi de me
ressourcer dans ma foi pourquoi minutes
il a la main salon autrefois ils ne se
faisaient partie des moeurs c'est
héréditaire
il y avait une pression sociale très
très très forte
c'est une démarche de foi personnelle
est à la fois familial aussi parce qu'on
est tous pratiquants la maison fille
lisa enfin 46 c'est vraiment une
démarche fois c'est une valeur ceux qui
ne venaient pas la messe était était dit
que tu es et tu es mal considérés
surchargés tombé de telle sorte que même
dans un milieu qui musclent homicide
il arrive même que le fait de venir à la
messe et une réaction de minoritaires et
dans les milieux de travail surtout
c'est pas tout bien considéré je crois
que une heure par semaine consacrée aux
seniors
ce que je trouve que c'est bien qu'on
appelait tous les jours c'est dans des
il s'appelle claude julien il a 34 ans
il est animateur social
il a été prêtre célébrant la messe mais
plus attirés par les problèmes sociaux
que par les mystères ou par la liturgie
du moins aux grecs sont élevées
aujourd'hui loin de l'église établi il
s'occupe de coopératives de logements
destinés aux classes modestes
il est carrément en rébellion contre la
discipline ecclésiastique car il vit
maritalement avec une femme
alors on peut se poser la question
est-il encore prêtre profondément je
resterai plus dans son sac dans ce qu'on
appelle le rôle de prophète c'est à dire
de présence au milieu du monde de
présence d' amour et cette erreur
il ya peut-être deux églises finalement
il y aurait l'église visée l'église des
célébrations et l'église la liturgie des
sacrements
tout ce qui est officier alix lui est de
plus en plus présente au milieu dans les
milieux préférablement moins favorisés
dans dans les endroits où il ya où il ya
de moins d'argent ou ou des valeurs de
solidarité et d'amour se vivent près
alité elle est là présente mais je
dirais presque invisible c'est un tu
peux les 10 d'ici là non il n'ya pas une
église opprimés par une autre encore
moins par le pouvoir politique
bien au contraire l'église catholique du
québec semble aller exactement dans la
ligne du concile vatican ii et il ne
reste pas grand-chose de l'institution
quasi totalitaire qui lie à moins d'un
quart de siècle imposait au québec sa
discipline de fer
question de temps demain thème la
radiologie c'est à dire les examens
radiologiques et leurs conséquences les
doses de rayons x que nous accumulons au
cours de notre vie à coude examen
peut-être de mettre systématique ou de
routine
il y avait plus de 60 millions pratiquer
des vernières en france or il existe un
risque statistique et des études le
prouvent bien entendu il n'est nullement
question de nier l'utilité médicale des
rayons x mais simplement de prévenir des
risques éventuels
alors pour répondre aux questions que
chacun est en droit de se poser là
dessus yves guillemot a consulté les
meilleurs spécialistes actuels pour le
question de temps de m'asseoir qui sera
présentée par louis blériot cyclisme et
bien le critérium national de la route
s'est terminée à draguignan par la
victoire de laurent avec un succès de
bernard hinault dans la dernière étape
ce qui rassure les innombrables
admirateurs de numéro 1 français sur sa
condition physique
un commentaire de jean paul aux lycées
lino de toute façon n'était pas
dangereux au classement final michel
laurent ne pouvait plus être battu
en passant saluant la bonne performance
ici de jean rené bernaudeau qui n'est
pas un spécialiste dijon du contre la
montre
il va prendre une méritoire 6e place à
49 secondes dino et va terminer deuxième
au classement final ovion le leader
vainqueur de la première étape
ancien champion de france on le disait
sur le déclin il a confondu ses
détracteurs vainqueur donc de cette
première étape il souffre contre la
montre ici car ce n'est pas sa
spécialité non plus il sera troisième au
classement final lui le ressusciter
regardez le dans le dernier kilomètre il
souffre
une fête un petit peu de bec de sel
comme l'on dit dans les milieux
cyclistes
le vainqueur le voici michel laurent il
ne finira que quatrième contre la montre
mais remportera la victoire finale
elle était attendue
la formation peugeot la sienne rafle
tout paris nice tour de corse tour du
haut var et maintenant critérium
national
un beau coup de chapeau course dès le
dernier dimanche d'auteuil avant le
point culminant de la saison qui sera
dimanche prochain le prix du président
de la république institue de chaises que
nous présenterons en direct aujourd'hui
au contraire le tiercé se disputer dans
une course de haies pour paul n 4 ans
avec à peu près tous les meilleurs
spécialistes de la génération victoire
de la casaque de monsieur andré michel
grasa gurkha entraîné par jean françois
doz main et ce malgré un départ parce
que désastreux le terrain était très
lourd cet après midi à auteuil pour les
vingt concurrents du tiercé qui se sont
élancés sur les 3600 mètres de la course
de haies de printemps en cours de route
le 9 et le 19 ont été mis hors course et
dans le dernier tournant c'est visant
futé qui a pris le commandement devant
burqa et agapes et us suivi de val
d'ajol béni sima ekoli voyant qu'ils
commencent à peiner dans le terrain
défoncé pour sauter l'avant-dernière e
et burqa est toujours en tête et laure
hellboy qui porte un poids élevé est un
terrible effort pour remonter à ses
côtés val d'ajol a pris le relais de
valley garé son compagnon d'écurie tu
sembles avoir eu un problème pendant le
parcours
val d'ajol s'accrochent courageusement
mes fils d'ecajeul ne se laisse pas
déborder les chevaux sont la dernière
les burqas val d'ajol et le ras-le-bol
sont sur la ligne mais c'est sur le plat
que va se jouer l'arrivée après avoir
sauté aux obstacles et parcouru plus de
3000 m le poids se fait son cours et la
classe pure a dû verser aux autres lieux
qu'à val d'ajol fil des pages est les
petits poids de la course sont à la
lutte mais le real boyd malvo ses 69 kg
sauve l'honneur et prend tout de même la
deuxième place arrive et 17 de 15 du rck
alors hellboy et physique à jeunes
intercepté rapporté dans
forcément 3530 250 et dans le désordre
pour 5 francs 7 106 francs 50
alors voyons le temps pour demain et
bien ma foi je vous dirai d'abord qu'il
y a eu des cigognes aperçu en lorraine
par conséquent le printemps est là
véritablement et non pas seulement sur
le papier prévisions météo sur demain
pour demain pardon et bien sûr les alpes
persisteront des résidus pluvio neigeux
sur la moitié nord ouest de la france de
l'aquitaine aux ardennes
on observera une hausse des températures
minimales le ciel deviendra nuageux avec
quelques pluies
ailleurs le temps sera variable avec des
brumes matinales et une alternance de
passages nuageux et d'éclaircies
je disais le printemps presque pas tout
à fait ce soir vous avez rendez vous
avec hervé claude demain antennes de
midi présenté par patrick lecocq à 20
heures patrick poivre d'arvor est
question de temps présenté par louis
blériot sur la radiologie notre région
est terminée bonsoir merci